hello there open ai's clip
and ali have been out for centuries now
what centuries miss coffee bean
it's been only three weeks now but i
think you
all agree with us that's three weeks in
machine
learning feel like a century meanwhile
google published the switch transformer
of
1 trillion parameters transformers
generate
music transformers generate 3d dance
motion
transformers detect 3d objects and the
list goes on and on
so let's stay cool and avoid being
overwhelmed
in a previous video where we discussed
openai's dal-e
we found out that it is great at
generating images from
natural language and it might look like
creativity
especially when combining concepts like
armchair
and avocado to make sure that daley's
generations are fitting the description
well
openai employed a separate model called
clip to rank these image generations
after their similarity to
the text and if you don't know about
dali yet
check out our video about it linked in
the description below
it's worth it in this video we will talk
about this helper model of dali
called clip but do not be deceived by
us calling it a helper model it is
more than impressive also on its own
make sure to stay until the end where we
will show what amazing things people
already did with
clip clip stands for contrastive
language image pre-training and yes the
paper has
a different title altogether anyway
based on the paper we will be answering
the questions
what can clip do what are the
ingredients for its success
what are the limitations of clip because
there are
some and what can we mortals do
with clip and what applications already
exist
based on clip because in comparison to
dali clip was already shared by open ai
clip is very good at telling if an image
and a short piece of text belong
together or not
but why do we even want to know if a
given text and image
fit well together in the first place
well because this task formulation
is general enough to derivate many other
tasks from it
like image recognition on imagenet for
example
the task there is to classify images
and this is what neural networks have
been doing so far
they take all available classes in the
data set
here the dog races and up to 1000 other
classes
and assign a probability for each class
the highest scoring class is the
classification prediction of the model
here king charles spaniel but with
clip it gets even better because of the
way it was trained
clip is not restricted to the classes
from the data set
but knows virtually all english words
being able to formulate the imagenet
classes into
prompts containing more language than
just the classes
and here we already see why clip has the
potential to be so much better than its
competitors
firstly it can also model the notion of
photo
or image or satellite extending its
capabilities far
over a restricted set of classes showing
great
zero shot performance on unseen data
sets
secondly clip is during training never
restricted to reduce an image to a
single concept or word
therefore it never loses or forgets
other aspects
of the image that are not captured in
class like the grass or
wood on the background impressively but
not
perfectly clip can solve tasks and data
sets it has not explicitly
seen during training like optical
character recognition
geo-localization texture detection
and others like facial emotion
recognition and action recognition
it is impressive zero shot performance
for a model trained only to predict the
similarity between a text prompt and an
image
then what are the ingredients of clips
success
here we have to say that the employed
ideas are
not really novel there are a lot of
ideas
used in the clip paper that were already
used in research
and openai's merit is definitely that it
managed to put everything together
in a fine piece of engineering which her
clip
is yes the zero shot capabilities of
clip are impressive but not unexpected
we have seen it happen too with gpt 3
trained on huge amounts of data with
high variance
clip has been trained on 400 million
images with paired text descriptions
this is 100 times more data than
imagenet and it is
very diversified data too because it was
all scraped from the internet
so the first ingredient for the success
of clip is of course the data
the more data the better and the more
diversified
the data the more we can expect the
model to be able to perform
afterwards in zero shot then
on this data it was trained like this
the authors take
a batch of images and the batch of their
corresponding
texture descriptions the images are
encoded by either a resnet or a
transformer
and the text is encoded by a transformer
too
then for each image in the batch the
encoder computes
an image vector so the first image
corresponds to the vector
i1 the nth image to i n
and the same happens for the textual
description
the first textural sequence is encoded
by one vector t1
the nth description by tn then the magic
happens
and square similarities are computed
between
all these images and text vectors this
means that the diagonal elements
of this matrix should be all maximized
by clip
as i1 fits with t1
i2 with t2 and so on
then in a contrastive fashion the off
diagonal
elements should be minimized since we
assume that it is really unlikely
that an image i1 fits with a random
other description other than its own
and that was the second ingredient of
the success of clip
is the idea of predicting similarities
between images and textual descriptions
and training in this contrastive fashion
but the idea is not new at all because
we have been
seeing this idea in multimodal
transformers
as a pre-training task like for example
in alex mert
wilbert visual bird and so on so this
is sadly some piece of related work that
we think the authors did not acknowledge
enough
and didn't compare to well the
third element that the authors advertise
clip with
is its computational efficiency
especially when these image and text
encoders are
transformers we know that a lot of
computations can run
in parallel compared to lstms for
example
but do not confound computational
efficiency with data efficiency
especially with transformers that do not
have inductive biases that help during
learning from little data
they need more data to learn well so
they are not
that data efficient so the fourth
ingredient to clips success comes from
the image and text representations
gained during training on the given data
clip now trained to predict high
similarity for fitting image text pairs
and low similarity for random ones is
ready to be applied on various tasks
like
image recognition we remember
image recognition only has one word to
describe one image
clip rather likes more words like a
description
so the authors create a prompt a photo
of a and then they insert all possible
objects creating as many prompts as
there are objects
then they compute zero shot the
similarity between
say imagenet image and these prompts
that
differ only in the mentioned object then
the prompt and object with the high
similarity is chosen as
prediction and the same clip model
performs really well
not only on the classical imagenet image
recognition challenge but on many other
tasks with different kinds of images
or styles because first it has
seen these image styles during training
and secondly it has seen the words to
describe these kinds of
images and their details okay so clip
can do
so much and it is time to see what the
limitations
are of clip here we must refer to the
limitations section of the clip paper
because it is the most entertaining
limitations section
we have ever read we include the
passages we refer to
and cite so you don't think that the
used language is really ours
no they really really formulate things
like we
show them here so the authors make clear
that
zero shot clip is competitive with the
baseline of
a supervised resnet 50 model trained
specifically on the training set of that
data set
and this is impressive because it means
that clip trained on openai's data set
of 400 million images
absorbs us a little from training
specifically on
tasks and the data sets associated to
them
but here the authors warn us that it is
still work
needed to beat the supervised baselines
but
this work can have limitations if it is
done
how the authors did it so far they warn
us that
if we scale the model and the data like
they
did so far we would need a thousand
times more resources in compute which is
infeasible with current hardware then
the second limitation they tell us about
is that
while clip is performing amazingly on
some zero-shot tasks
it is not amazing on all
tasks besides the performance of
clip is poor on several types of
fine-grained classification such as
differentiating models of cars species
of flowers and variants of aircrafts and
clip has also trouble with abstract and
systematic tasks such as counting the
number of objects in an image
clip has also trouble with tasks that
are unlikely
in the pre-training data set by saying
that clip has
troubles generalizing to out of
distribution images
and they illustrate with an example of
optical character recognition where clip
is really good at
recognizing digitally rendered text but
has troubles with
mnist which is a data set containing
handwritten digits
and the reason the authors can identify
is that
there are a lot of digitally rendered
text images
in clips training data but not so much
handwritten digits and clip
kind of fails to generalize from
digitally rendered text to handwritten
text
and kind of the next limitation they
address is that
clip is not a caption generator model
it can only tell you how a given an
existing image and an existing
text fit together but it cannot really
compose
new text and also a very beautiful
formulation clip
also i said clip does not address the
poor data efficiency of deep learning
instead clip compensates by using a
source of supervision that can be scaled
to hundreds of millions of training
examples
so clip didn't solve any of the deep
learning
problems but it kind of shows a bigger
hammer
for solving the problem okay but now
that we
know what the authors found out that
clip cannot do
let's have a short look at what people
have been able to do
with the clip model that was released by
openai
and the first application we want to
show you
is this one by labmember001
who was able to discern between
grainy noisy photos and high quality
photos he could really nicely formulate
in natural language because clip
understands that so in a sense clip can
be used as
an image search engine as for example
vladimir
did who used clip to retrieve car images
but it gets even better
he could retrieve even more details
things like car
driving in the woods so this is the best
thing about clip you can describe the
model
very detailed what you want and you can
retrieve pictures
like this one where it's raining cats
and dogs and also
what i really liked is this example of
detecting chemical elements in pictures
clip delivers us similarities or scores
between an image and a text so it can be
easily used as a discriminator in again
here is a super nice example of a
montreal
image find the links to the tweets we
have shown you so far
in the description below and also in the
description please find the link to this
google collab released by openai
where you get working code that you can
explore in your own applications
there are detailed instructions how to
download and initialize the model
and then there is even an example how to
calculate similarities between
images and pieces of text and also how
to create your own
imagenet like classifier with clip so
you can play with clip on collab
yourself
do not forget to find all the links
mentioned in the description below
let us know what cool things you have
created with clip in the comments
and see you next time
you